Through helping Grant mull over this cleaning solution issue, we learned about
the use and the importance of points of intersections on graphs. When two lines
cross one another, the coordinates of the point where that happens give us
values of variables that satisfy the equations of all of the lines that pass
through that point. So, we are able to use this knowledge to solve for different
variables. We could just take the equations corresponding to either line, figure
out how to set one side of one equation equal to one side of the other equation,
and then solve for the unknown variable. That would give us a new coordinate of
that point of intersection. But, what if instead we didn't have a graph? What if
you just had an equation, and not just any equation but an equation with one
variable, something like 3 x plus 4 equals 19? Now that we know we can find
values for variables through finding points of intersection of lines, can you
think of two lines we could graph whose point of intersection would help us
solve this equation? Please put a two variable equation in each of these boxes
that we could graph on the same coordinate plane to help us work with this
equation. This definitely requires a little bit of outside the box thinking. So,
just give it a try.